You can see here that the cost to make 92 wiper sets is equal to 598. But we
also see in the last equation, that the cost to make 92 wiper sets is equal to
the cost to make one wiper set times the number of wiper sets made. Now, when
two quantities are both equal to the same thing, that means they're also equal
to each other. That means we can say that 598 equals the cost to make one wiper
set times the number of wiper sets made. That's actually really just another
case of substitution. So, we can put a 598 in this spot, and we're going to
continue to leave dollar signs out for now just for simplicity. You see the cost
to make one wiper set, both here and the last equation, and also here that it's
equal to c. So, let's substitute c in and the number wiper sets made is 92. Now,
we have an equation. 598 equals c times 92. There's one slight adjustment that
I'm going to make. I'm going to say that 598 equals 92c. So, remember that we
normally write the coefficients, just plain numbers, at the front of terms and
then the variables following them. So, look at that. After a lot of hard work,
we finally have a lovely, concise equation. 598 equals 92c. I'm going to put a
nice little box around that.